las vegas land developer wants to make
home ownership possible for first time
buyers this is a future site of
independence town homes on vegas valley
near hollywood as jeremy j ford reports
this development aims to help renters
become homeowners we're doing a
groundbreaking for our latest project
and our biggest project we've ever built
president and owner of touchstone living
tom mccormick is developing more than
1500 new homes there will be some
commercial 30 acres of parks playgrounds
pools
there'll be nothing else like it here in
las vegas take cigar bloom the district
e county commissioner agrees they're
still almost 300 thousand dollars so
it's not like
they're just giving them away but the
fact is if you look around the valley
this this is affordable the way they
finance it the way they include
everything else with prices starting in
the 200 000 range sieger bloom says this
is the largest undertaking he will see
as county commissioner it's almost a
square mile but it is so fun to see this
is not someone where we have acre lots
this is a place where
real people who have real jobs can live
which he says is the future of modern
home buying we can't all have houses
with lawns and big yards and pools so
we're going to have to learn to combine
our resources have town homes that allow
anyone to become a first time homeowner
housing is
is a great wealth creator for people
and this is where it starts in las vegas
jeremy j ford live local now